it's a constant process of like
suffering and passion and love we're
just learning that and navigating that
and doing that together Megan Fox and
Machine Gun Kelly trying to keep their
twin flames burning on the first day you
told me I was your twin flame from a
past life a source tells E.T the
couple's making an effort to work out
their issues despite reports they're
struggling it's definitely a process
it's not an easy one our source ads
things have been getting better between
Megan and MGK and the singer's been
going out of his way to make sure she
feels happy loved and secure with him
love is probably the biggest project
I've ever worked on yeah so yeah
everything encompassing that I put you
know I I give
that more energy than I give my work so
in February rumors swirled the pair
called it quits this after Megan posted
these pics to Instagram alongside
cryptic lyrics from Beyonce's 2016 album
lemonade
[Music]
eagle-eyed fans also noticed the actress
unfollowed The Rocker and deleted all
pics of him from her page The Source at
the time told E.T the two got into a big
argument before his performance at a
Super Bowl event in Arizona following
that Megan and MGK were spotted leaving
a marriage counseling office we've done
every form of therapy that exists some
of it's really difficult but
that our therapist said that our
relationship is basically the process of
breaking each other down but most people
don't have the tools to build each other
back up to rebuild now months after that
drama things are looking up for the
lovebirds
[Music]
making an MGK were recently spotted in
Hawaii together our source says they
enjoy being together and love one
another so they're trying to get to a
good and solid Place adding they both
have so much fun together and feel
comfortable with one another and that
hasn't changed sticking with a journey
and crossing fingers and hoping
[Music]
thank you